chile is a south american wilderness
isolated from the rest of the continent
the country is a mosaic of different
landscapes
none are quite as hostile as the atacama
desert
these are thirsty lands some areas
haven't seen rain since history books
began
it's the driest desert on earth
where water has to be salvaged from
unusual sources
risk is an everyday reality
creatures in chile's atacama desert
adapt
or die
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the atacama is one of the most
unforgiving places
on earth
[Music]
stretching across northern chile and
straddling
four countries the atacama desert is
almost as big as cuba
other than earth's poles no other place
in the world is drier than here
the wettest areas receive only half an
inch of rain a year
but in the desert center as far as
history knows
it has never rained every corner of the
compass reveals nothing but sand
stretching as far as the eye can see
[Music]
it seems impossible that anything can
live here
despite the bleak prospects of life if
you know how
there are ways of surviving
the animals of the atacama never
overlook opportunity
and when they find it they fight to the
death to defend it
[Music]
in the middle of the atacama life
congregates around any source of water
the salar to atacama is the largest salt
flat in chile
its waters are filtered down from the
andes almost 200 miles to the east
with no way to escape the mountain
plateau
the waters are trapped they slowly
evaporate
leaving behind a vast expanse of thick
salt crust
it's here that the atacama is host to a
salt flat fighter
at the lake's edge the fabian's lizard
is king
[Music]
there's not much to rule over but
whatever there is
he'll defend with unrestrained ferocity
and he doesn't do it alone an
unusual and ingenious lizard
[Music]
he would be nothing without his partner
in crime
[Music]
this female is his honey trap
her job is to distract invading males
with sexual pheromones
allowing her mate to ambush the
unsuspecting intruder
[Music]
they use the highest salt crust as a
lookout
from here they can survey their land and
spot any would-be usurpers
[Music]
it isn't long before a trespasser
catches their eye
[Music]
the scaly temptress wastes no time
before flirting with the enemy
[Music]
he's enticed by her advances but of
course
it's too good to be true
her partner spies on them from a
distance waiting for the perfect moment
a signal from her and he charges into
battle
he puffs himself out to intimidate his
competitor
but his rivals no power
the two salt flat fighters go for the
kill
[Music]
after countless throwdowns the intruder
is desperate to escape
but this lizard's forte is fighting
[Music]
finally the intruder is allowed to leave
a little battered and bruised
the couple have a good reason for
defending this patch
their main source of food is swarming
in the heat of the day black clouds of
flies descend on the water's edge
for the lizards catching them is an art
form
[Music]
but this isn't the case for everyone
this andy and lap wings methods are a
little less sophisticated
there's little else to eat but there are
plenty of flies to go around
what little life exists here has been
isolated for a long time
it's had to adapt to the hostile climate
of the atacama
the waters here have a similar salt
concentration to the dead sea
too high to sustain much but what there
is
entices the desert's most flamboyant
residents
flamingos
[Music]
these birds wear pink but they're no
delicate dancers
everything about them is tailored to
counter the punishing conditions
they've spent 30 million years
biologically evolving
to the demands of life
they're specially adapted to these
brackish waters
[Music]
flamingos are one of the few animals on
earth that are able to drink the water
just because they can cope here doesn't
mean that life's easy for chile's
flamingos
in the early afternoon heat the air in
the atacama
grows restless
the rising temperatures create dust
devils that
churn their way across the landscape at
speeds of up to 45 miles per hour
a reminder of just how unwelcome life is
in the atacama desert
the conditions of the atacama desert are
more similar to the surface of mars
than anywhere else on earth
[Music]
so much so that nasa comes here to help
unlock the secrets of the red planet
this desert is 50 times more arid than
california's death valley
as well as being the driest desert in
the world
the atacama is also one of the oldest
it hasn't changed much in 150 million
years
bacteria in the soils of the atacama
could hold the key to the beginning of
planetary life
in the middle of the desert this lagoon
is home to one of the oldest forms of
life
on earth
these stromatolite structures are made
from layer upon layer of very
simple bacteria
life on earth as we know it owes its
existence to these modest looking lumps
it's this bacteria that first introduced
oxygen
into the planet's atmosphere allowing
life on earth to explode the waters of
the lagoon reveal
more of the world's ancient life forms
[Music]
triops
these little creatures are one of the
oldest animal species still in existence
unchanged for more than 70 million years
they're born survivors able to withstand
very warm
alkaline waters
today these skills are evident in the
atacama's other inhabitants
more than merely salt lake experts
flamingos are one of the few animals
able to withstand the caustic soda
found in the desert's thermal pools
chile is home to more than 300
geothermal fields
spots where heat from deep within the
molten earth
can be felt on the surface most of them
can be found in the atacama
some are more noticeable than others
[Music]
more than 80 geysers are dotted
throughout the desert
chile's most famous are the el tatio
geysers
it's the biggest cluster of geysers in
the southern hemisphere
and the third largest on earth
located 14 000 feet above sea level
they belong to the highest geothermal
field in the world
at these altitudes water is a little
easier to come by
than in the deserts heartlands
snow melt from the nearby mountains
collects and forms small lakes on the
altiplano
at this altitude there are strange
creatures that call the water pools home
the giant coot lives up to its name
this water bird weighs 5 pounds
[Music]
huge feet allow them to carry their bulk
over floating weeds without sinking
this male is looking for building
material
giant coots are house proud
their entire day is dedicated to
constructing their nest
they work together with their partners
spending hours adding to the structure
with plants they've torn up from the
lake bed
[Music]
there's a lot at stake for these
homeowners
trespassing isn't tolerated
[Music]
yet some coots aren't willing to put in
the time to do their own home
improvements
[Music]
nest looting in this neighborhood is
rife
[Music]
enough's enough this kud isn't having it
[Music]
he sets his sights on the latest thief
and charges after
him giant coots can't really fly
but their incredibly powerful legs and
huge crab-like feet
allow them to blaze through the water
when the homeowner catches up with the
thief he initiates the coot version
of kickboxing
though this might look silly there's a
lot of power behind
each slap the claws on the end of the
coot's feet
are incredibly sharp
in the chaos of the fight they've
trespassed onto another neighbor's
territory
[Music]
the fight has now escalated into a brawl
[Music]
finally exhausted everyone cools off
but the piece will definitely be
short-lived with tempers like these
as the sun sets shadows in chile's
altiplano stretch their way up the banks
of the andes
meanwhile in the desert's dry and dusty
interior
an unlikely animal remains wide awake
in the middle of chile's atacama desert
the skies are clear nearly 24 hours a
day
even clouds don't venture into the
seemingly desolate wasteland
and because of their absence
temperatures at night
are near freezing
it's now that one of the atacama's most
surprising
inhabitants must draw on some serious
fortitude to get through the night
the grey gull nests here in the desert
make no mistake these are sea birds
for years no one knew where the
seemingly ordinary birds went to nest
then they were stumbled upon in 1945
here in the driest desert in the world
but these gulls aren't lost this is
actually a perfect example of the
ingenuity of the atacama's animals
they could be here because there are
barely any predators
in that sense it's the perfect spot to
raise a family
but that perk comes with several catches
the parents must take turns traveling
more than 60 miles to the coast
to collect food and water for their
chicks
daytime brings even more challenges
as the temperature rises these eggs
could cook
in the baking hot soils
in the hottest part of the day the
parent on duty must stand over the eggs
keeping them in the shade
it's a selfless act in these
temperatures
but the gulls are well adjusted to life
here the colors of their feathers are
thought to be an
adaptation enabling them to radiate heat
even the eggs are well designed for the
desert
[Music]
their hard impervious shell means little
moisture evaporates from inside the egg
in fact 30 percent less than some other
desert nesting birds
[Music]
when they're old enough the chicks take
turns giving each other shade
[Music]
but mom always makes a better sunshield
some don't survive this perilous start
to life
but those that do won't wait long before
making their first pilgrimage to the
shore
[Music]
after around 40 days and 40 nights in
the desert
grey gold chicks finally fledge and
follow their parents to the ocean
the eastern edge of the pacific awaits
them
at the midway mark of the atacama's
coastline the desert is littered with
boulders and rocks
here the sea batters the shore with
furious waves
often 25 feet tall
despite the odds it's on this turbulent
border
that the atacama pacific iguana has made
a successful enterprise
like its name suggests this lizard
bridges the gap
between desert and ocean
they're another of the atacama's unusual
lizards
but like all reptiles they're pretty
lazy in the morning
they begin the day with a bit of
sunbathing to raise their metabolism
[Music]
they need all the energy they can get
for what's in store
as the sun rises and low tide approaches
pacific lizards begin
checking the ocean
climbing to a higher point they can
survey the water
they're not here out of curiosity
they know all too well what the water
can do
these lizards are not built for swimming
and they stand no chance in these waves
that's why what they do next is so
surprising
these rocks are covered in nutrient-rich
algae
a veritable feast in this area
timing is everything
the lizards risk life and limb to reach
the precious food
eating as much as they can before
scuttling back to safety
not only could they be swept away but
the cold waters mean the lizard loses a
lot of energy retrieving a meal
each trip has to be countered with
moments of rest in the sun
but it's a fair trade-off for food that
can't run away
[Music]
the waters on the coast of chile are
especially icy
they come from a polar ocean
the humboldt current is several degrees
colder than the rest of the pacific
strong winds drive this slow cold stream
of water up the western edge of chile
from antarctica
the humboldt reaches 600 miles wide and
is as deep as the sea floor
the cold water upwelling brings with it
nutrient-rich debris
from the sea bed which phytoplankton
thrive on
and in turn hundreds of ocean animals
come to feast on the riches of chile's
coastline
with such an abundance of water and food
the humboldt seems to have nothing in
common with the desert that runs
alongside it
but in fact this current is what makes
the atacama so dry
the cold air above the humboldt acts as
a vacuum
for airborne moisture
fog and mists hover as banks of cloud
over chile's shoreline
trapped by a collision of air pressure
but for a few hours every day warmer
temperatures release the fog
and it moves up the cliffs toward the
desert
warming into the edge of the atacama
this is known as the kamenchaka
strong winds accompany this fog
phenomenon
[Music]
the desert is encased in seconds
for a few hours nearly every day the
fringes of the atacama are drenched in
fine water droplets
it's a lifeline for animals and plants
on the edge of survival
here cactus flourish in the path of the
mists
[Music]
and are even covered in water loving
lichen
an oasis for the atacama's animals
but the fog will last only an hour or
two
so they must seize the opportunity while
it lasts
the kamen chaka entices a surprising
creature out of hiding
hummingbirds are usually only found
among forests and flowers
but the daily fog makes life on the edge
of the desert
possible for the oasis hummingbird
on chile's coastline they capitalize on
the riches
of the kamenchaka
their long bills allow them to extract
nectar from the flowering cacti
like most hummingbirds they have a high
metabolism
and need to eat a lot of nectar to
survive
these birds have a live fast die young
policy
their long tongues are capable of
gathering nectar at a rate of 20
licks per second
almost as fast as they're flying
their wings are a blur as they beat
almost 50 times per second
with all this activity their heart rate
can exceed
1 000 beats per minute
[Music]
without the kamen chaka there's no way
there would be enough nectar to fuel
these tiny powerhouses
these are true desert opportunists
[Music]
the kamin chaka's reach isn't enough to
sustain animals and plants further
inland in chile's dry interior
in these soils even bacteria struggle to
survive
despite the odds every so often in the
north
the desert sees an event nothing short
of a miracle
seeds that have been dormant for years
erupt into life
fragile looking flowers fight their way
through the sandy soils
the desert is alive with a superbloom
[Applause]
[Music]
more than 200 species of plants spring
up to remind chile of their existence
this is a triumph of resilience
aside from its beauty the flowering
desert is a banquet for both beast
and beetle a surprise windfall
for the animals of the atacama
elsewhere in the desert the impact of
rain
feels different
the soils of the atacama aren't well
adapted for holding water
they quickly become overburdened
triggering landslides that completely
reshape the landscape
for humans the results are catastrophic
but for nature these landslides are
regenerative
nutrients are churned up and released
and life
thrives in their wake
[Music]
water that soaks through the desert to
lowlands easily carves a path through
the sand
creating miniature canyons
hidden beneath the horizon these are
ribbons of life
in a seemingly empty sandpit
hidden gullies conceal a surprising
resident
they might look out of place here but
mountain parakeets thrive in the atacama
desert
these feathery fluff balls make this
canyon a metropolis
they're incredibly social birds and
spend
all day together in big friendly groups
they preen and chatter to reinforce
strong bonds
but that doesn't mean they don't have
bffs
the reason behind their bright green
color becomes obvious when they stop to
drink
the mineral-rich water carpets the
canyon in algae and grasses
camouflaging the green parakeets and
airborne predators just fly on by
these narrow channels are a surprising
eden
in a vast wilderness of dirt
in the south of chile's atacama desert
rains have a more
obvious effect in the landscape
in a matter of days the dry yellows and
browns of the desert
are replaced by rich emerald
this unexpected good fortune for the
animals of the atacama
attracts visitors to the fertile plains
a south american gray fox is here to
hunt down a mate
for the first time in his life
the desert can be a lonely place and the
drive to reproduce
is all-consuming
[Music]
he might have only one shot at finding a
mate this season
so it's important to be thorough
a stranger to this area he makes his
mark on every surface available
this scent trail is the fox's version of
a flag
he's staking a claim to the territory
and
access to any females in it
[Music]
[Music]
it seems he's found a lead on a local
lady
he lets out a greeting
out here the sound travels for miles
[Music]
the female hears him
uncertain if he's a threat she's
cautious
she provides him with a coded message
[Music]
her urine reveals her reproductive
status
it's the beginning of courtship
proceedings
[Music]
finally he tracks her down before he can
approach
he demonstrates submission so she
understands his intentions
but he's a little over eager and she's
not making it easy
wrapping her tail around her body is her
way of denying him
[Music]
he'll have to try harder than this if he
wants to win her over
[Music]
it's going to be an exhausting few days
[Music]
if he forgets to pay attention to her
she has ways of reminding him to up his
game
[Music]
this pair will remain together for five
more months
before they go their separate ways in
that time
with any luck they'll leave behind a
legacy in the form
of up to four offspring
the rains have provided a temporary
relief from desolate dust lands
but there are many places in the atacama
that have no hope of seeing water
falling from the sky
instead life here has to source moisture
from the ground
but that's easier said than done
the salar de pintaros is an ancient lake
bed
the soil has extremely high
concentrations of salt
[Music]
it's nearly impossible for anything to
grow much less live
plants that survive here have learned to
adapt over
thousands of years as a result
more than 60 percent of the flora found
in the atacama
is found nowhere else on earth
in this dry wasteland the tamarugo tree
is an island of life in a sea of salt
[Music]
a magnet for all manner of creatures
[Music]
in the blazing sun the inside of the
tamarugos canopy
is a sanctuary from the heat
for ancient nomads crossing the desert
this would have been the only natural
shelter for miles and in the right
season
the tree even bears a protein-rich fruit
the secret of this seemingly miracle
tree lies underground
deep thick roots tap into the water
table
sucking up moisture trapped in the earth
remnants of rainwater
filtered from the andes
[Music]
remarkably the tomarugo has a modest
ancestor
this is a flowering member of the pea
family
an unlikely master of the desert
the atacama is an unforgiving realm of
chilean wilderness
the desert covers more than 10 percent
of the entire country
dictating hardships for every living
creature that dares to exist within its
[Music]
borders
the animals of the atacama are
enterprising risk takers
defending opportunity and resources at
every turn
their lives depend on it
only those that dare survive chile's
borderlands
[Music]
you